vérité poursuit elle c'est ce que
réclame la famille de ce jeune homme de
19 ans a battu lors d'un contrôle de
police en août dernier dans le 3e
arrondissement de marseille pour se
faire entendre elle a organisé une
mobilisation de trois jours principal
objectif réclamer justice pour soi elle
et pour toutes les autres victimes de
violences policières
tu en colère colère contre les
institutions qui ne m'ont pas considéré
depuis le début de la depuis la mort de
mon fils où j'ai eu j'ai été contacté
par personne ni le procureur ni la
police mais personne n'a donné aucune
version le 4 août dernier alors qu'il se
trouve dans le quartier de la belle de
mai le jeune homme est contrôlé par la
police qui reconnaît son véhicule lier
un délit de fuite la veille sous l aile
khalfaoui redémarre et percute l'un des
agents un autre fonctionnaire tir avec
son arme de service et touche le
conducteur au thorax une enquête de
l'igpn a été ouverte pour homicide
involontaire et une autre confiée à la
police judiciaire concernant le jeune
homme pour violences avec arme sur
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique
de son côté la famille déposent plainte
fin août elle remet en question la
légitime défense prévue par la loi du 28
février 2010 est une loi qui donne la
possibilité pour les policiers de tirer
sur un conducteur qui refuserait
d'obtempérer
la voiture étant considéré comme une
arme par destination
il est très facile pour un policier de
faire usage de cette notion de la
légitime défense à chaque fois qu'il
tire sur quelqu'un ce qui est triste
c'est qu'en fait ça soit nous familles
qui devions qui devons en fait nous
former qui devons apprendre qui devons
comprendre les limites en fait de cette
de cette loi
au programme de la mobilisation ateliers
témoignages mais aussi débats parmi les
thèmes abordés celui de la réalité de la
menace ou encore de la nécessité de la
riposte des collectifs sont également
présents pour soutenir la famille dans
son combat comme le collectif urgence
notre police à 6 ne fondée par un mâle
benton si elle a perdu son frère en 2012
et après un long combat judiciaire le
policier mis en cause a été condamné
au delà de la sphère de mon flair pour
moi il était important de mettre toutes
ces histoires de familles qui subissent
cette répression ces drames depuis
depuis des années déjà et j'ai voulu
qu'on soit visible tous ensemble de
façon à monter un collectif pour conter
une page facebook et au quotidien parler
de ces histoires dénoncé pointé du doigt
concernant la plainte de la famille de
swell le procureur de la république a
jusqu'au 23 novembre prochain pour
rendre sa décision
en attendant la famille espère avoir
accès aux éléments de l'enquète de
l'igpn ainsi qu'au rapport du légiste